2022 kurzer Blick zurück wohnt wie haben
sie gefeiert wo waren sie Weihnachten
wie immer zu Hause im Sauerland ja
Jahreswechsel Berlin teilweise teilweise
in Berlin in Rom einen Tag bei der habe
ich sie gesehen
mit Freunden zusammen privat und aber
haben sie mitgekriegt ohne Böller ohne
Böller sie haben mich geböllert nein das
erste Mal auch keine Raketen
da wir haben andere geböllert und
geballert haben sie das mitgekriegt in
den Nachrichten okay
wie fällt in ihrer Erklärung auf wenn
Sie diese Bilder sehen für das was da
passiert ist ich finde es ganz
grauenhaft und ich muss sagen ich bin
erschrocken auch über die
Gewalttätigkeit gegen die Polizei gegen
Rettungskräfte gegen Unbeteiligte
private Familien die da betroffen waren
und ich finde wir sollten mindestens
genauso sehr über die Opfer reden wie
über die Täter aber wenn hier einige
dieser Straftäter ganz offen auch Waffen
tragen
die auch vorne beladen werden mit
brennbaren geschossen dann ist das
einfach völlig inakzeptabel und dagegen
müssen wir wirklich etwas tun das ist
klar ich glaube da sind uns hier in der
Runde auch alle eigentlich aber ihre
Erklärung dafür warum
eskaliert das so
ich denke wir haben in Deutschland über
zu viel Zeit zu lange Jahre weggeschaut
die Brennpunkte Brennpunkte sein lassen
können Sie hier in Hamburg anschauen
können Sie in Berlin in der Rigaer
Straße anschauen können Sie in Leipzig
Connewitz anschauen wenn sie unterm Jahr
weggucken wo sich solche Brennpunkte
entwickeln und solche rechtsfreien Räume
wo die Polizei kaum noch hingeht dann
dürfen sie sich nicht wundern wenn dann
am 1 Mai oder am 31 Dezember solche
Krawalle stattfinden also jetzt nach
unten Tischen zu rufen das müsste man
jetzt mal besprechen was da passiert ist
ist glaube ich völlig unzureichend wir
müssen von vornherein dafür sorgen dass
diese Leute die diesen Rechtsstaat
herausfordern dass sie sich nicht an die
Regeln halten wollen dass diesen Leuten
die Grenzen aufgezeigt werden und das
tun einige Länder nicht ausreichend
lass uns doch noch mal genauer hingucken
sie packen jetzt sozusagen die erste Mai
Randale in ein Pott mit dem was da
passiert ist oder ist das etwas anderes
was für da gesehen haben naja Randale
ist zunächst einmal Randale worandale
gegen den Staat ist meine sie können es
bisschen den heutigen Tag sehen was was
jetzt auch in diesem Stunden in
lützerath passiert ja dass da aus der
sogenannten Klimabewegung jetzt die
Polizei angegriffen wird das hat mit
Meinungsfreiheit und
Demonstrationsfreiheit nichts mehr zu
tun das sind Straftaten das sind
Gewalttaten von meistens jungen Männern
da hatte die Beobachtung recht dass das
überwiegend junge Männer sind nicht ganz
ausschließlich aber überwiegend junge
Männer sind wir müssen als Rechtsstaat
Bundesrepublik Deutschland diesen
Gewalttaten früher begegnen und den muss
man zeigen dass das nicht geht und zwar
sehr klar und sehr deutlich aber nochmal
lützerat Frage auch immer verladen und
auch von Eva Weg 1 Mai lutzerat das was
da passiert ist da sehen sie eine
Verbindung ne ich sehe die Verbindung
das ist hier offensichtlich eine ganz
kleine aber schon relevante Gruppe von
jungen Männern gibt das sind zum Teil
aber nicht ausschließlich Männer mit
Migrationshintergrund wie wir so
vornehmen sagen die nicht bereit sind
sich an die Regeln dieses Landes dieser
Demokratie zu halten und da gegen muss
sich ein Staat zur Wehr setzen und zwar
sehr klar sehr deutlich und auch hart es
geht nicht anders
was da passiert ist alles also gibt es
für die für sie da sozusagen die
Gemeinsamkeit oder ist das was wir dann
Silvester gesehen haben noch mal was
anderes ich habe glaube ich selten so
häufig die Formulierung gelesen es hat
eine neue Qualität vorbei Qualität finde
ich kein gutes Wort ist in dem
Zusammenhang aber eine neue Dimension
eine neue Dimension richtig und zwar
weil eben nicht nur die Polizei
angegriffen worden ist was wir ja schon
häufiger gesehen haben sondern weil
systematisch auch Rettungskräfte
angegriffen worden sind und also
Rettungskräfte die dafür da sind Leben
zu retten dass da dann Leute hingehen
und die beschießen systematisch
versuchen die das zu zerstören die
wirklich an Leib und Leben zu bedrohen
das ist aus meiner Sicht die neue
Dimension und ansonsten sehe ich zwei
Stränge also ich wäre vorsichtig alles
in einen Topf zu schmeißen was wir an
Randale sehen in diesem Land es gibt
sicherlich in verschiedenen Gruppen
wachsende Respektlosigkeit Verachtung
gegenüber dem Staat und deshalb hat der
Verfassungsschutz ja auch aus gutem
Grund die neue Form eingeführt
Delegitimierung des Staates was man dann
aber von was aus ganz vielen
verschiedenen Gruppen kommt und wenn man
dann auf die Ursachen schaut dann kann
man glaube ich diese ganzen Gruppen
nicht zusammen nehmen aber wir sehen
dass der Staat unter verschiedenen unter
vielen
von vielen Seiten unter Druck ist und
das was wir jetzt in der Silvester Nacht
gesehen haben dass ist ja nicht nur in
Berlin eskaliert das ist ja auch in
Nordrhein-Westfalen eskaliert obwohl es
da seit vielen Jahren ein Innenminister
gibt der durchaus durchgreift und
trotzdem konnte er das nicht verhindern
zum Beispiel vielleicht können wir das
einmal kurz hier
da würde ich dann sagen muss man auf
jeden Fall muss der Staat sich stark
zeigen indem er schnell und auch hart
aburteilt also die Täter die
Verantwortlichen und dann muss man aber
auch in die Ursachen reingehen und da
sind sicherlich runde Tische nicht der
Weisheit letzter Schluss aber wenn man
sich dann eben die Feuerwehr fragt was
braucht ihr wenn man die Schulen fragt
was braucht ihr und und so weiter dann
kommt man dahin dass man den einzelnen
Gruppen aus denen diese diese Gewalt
kommt dass man an die rankommt weil das
ist ja eben auch wichtig man muss auf
der einen Seite Strafen und sagen so
geht es gar nicht also sind ganz klare
rote Linien ziehen aber dann muss man
natürlich auch gucken dass man an diese
Gruppen ran kommt man kann sie sich ähm
man kann nicht sagen das reicht dann
schon wenn wir abstrafen das reicht
nicht das kann in die Wut noch mal
vergrößern nein man muss rangehen man
muss die eskalieren und die Berliner
Polizei wenn ich das vielleicht noch
anfügen darf hat ja eine Zeit lang beim
ersten Mai nee die Eskalationsstrategie
gefahren die funktioniert hat und wo
dann auf einmal der erste Mai immer noch
nicht Kra wurde aber doch viel
friedlicher als früher und das muss man
dann nachdem man das klare Stoppschild
gesetzt hat nachdem man klar abgeurteilt
und die hat und die Täter bestraft hat
muss man sagen so und für den Rest
machen wir jetzt hier Angebote der
dskalation
erstmal schaue ich da drauf dass wir
2018 was ganz ähnliches hatten und die
Reaktion waren härtere Strafen aber
ansonsten hat man nicht viel getan und
entsprechend sehen wir die Bilder
wahrscheinlich in der neuen Qualität es
war 18 sie sie spielen jetzt worauf an
weil sie sagen 218 auf Silvester 20 18
auch 20 19 also habe ich schon völlig
verdrängt vor dem Jahr daraufhin wurden
die Strafen ähm verschärft und ähm
ansonsten ist wenig passiert und
entsprechend wiederholt sich das jetzt
erstmal zunächst aber klar dann muss man
durchgreifen das ist nicht in Ordnung
und gleichzeitig muss man aber
feststellen dass wir
dass wir das Phänomen zu tun mit dem
Phänomen zu tun haben das insgesamt die
Gewalt abnimmt und gerade bei
Jugendlichen die Jugend Gewalt abnimmt
das ist erstmal richtig wichtiger guter
Hinweis dass wir insgesamt
offenbar unsere Systeme unsere Erziehung
und so weiter so funktioniert dass das
ist rückläufig ist und zwar sehr
rückläufig ist das hoffe ich weil wir
weniger Kinder und Jugendliche haben in
diesem Land auch wenn man das
kontrolliert aber ein kleiner Kreis wie
es Friedrich Merz gerade richtig gesagt
hat hat eine kleine Gruppe umso
intensiver das will ich jetzt mal sagen
und und
quantitativ auch stärker Gewalt ausübt
aber was ist die Motivation ist es
Verachtung für diesen Staat ist es Frust
wenn ja worüber was ist das Thema dieser
dieser wütenden jungen Typen das sind
ganz unterschiedliche Motivlagen ich
meine die die die neuesten Erkenntnisse
deuten ja darauf hin dass es nicht nur
aus dem migrantischen Milieu war sondern
mittlerweile spricht man auch von
vermummten Mob ich zitiere die Polizei
Meldung also auch aus so wird vermutet
aus dem linken Milieu dass der sehr
vieles zusammengekommen ist und die
Motiv sagen sind sehr unterschiedlich
das was man insgesamt sagen kann so so
so ein Trend gerade jetzt ähm nach
Corona 2 Jahre ist es ausgefallen da hat
sich was angestaut aber auch und das ist
gerade für Rettungskräfte tragisch dass
wir insgesamt einen Trend haben dass das
Rollenträger das Funktionsträger zunimmt
mit weniger je weniger sozusagen
automatischem Respekt begegnet wird und
das sehen wir in allen möglichen
Kontexten ich war Lehrer einer Schule da
hat man das schon erlebt auch jetzt als
Universitätsprofessor erlebt man dass da
sozusagen eine größere Distanzlosigkeit
da ist auf einem ganz anderen Niveau
natürlich aber insgesamt sehen wir das
und wir sehen uns ja auch das
Rettungskräfte unabhängig von solchen
extrem Installation es häufiger erleben
dass selbst also
nichts damit zu tun migrantisch oder
nicht auch nicht mit arm oder reich die
Art und Weise wie sich die Gewalt und
die Aggression ausdrückt das ist
natürlich sehr unterschiedlich aber das
von Beschimpfung über
auch sozusagen so Form von Montage dass
man einfach keinen Platz macht dass man
keine Rücksicht nimmt für Rettung jetzt
im Hinblick auf Rettungskräfte das ist
ein allgemeines Phänomen dass wir seit
einigen Jahren erleben woher
jetzt könnte ich Ihnen sagen wir leben
zunehmend in der Gesellschaft in der wir
nicht mehr so ohne weiteres Hierarchien
akzeptieren das ist ja eigentlich eine
gute Entwicklung sondern Modernisierung
dass wir nicht mehr alles hinnehmen eine
bestimmte eine bestimmte Funktionsträger
sagt was so Autoritätshörigkeit das hat
alles abgenommen und dementsprechend sag
mal ist alles in Bewegung und wenn jetzt
andere soziale Problemlagen hinzukommen
dann
können können solche Problemstellungen
gerade für diejenigen eine Rolle spielen
aber weil sie gerade auch angesprochen
haben eine andere Motivlage kann sein
Distanz zum Start auch so eine
Verachtung im Staat gegenüber und
das ist eine eine ganz andere Geschichte
das haben wir auch gesehen bei den
corona-protesten da hat es die Polizei
und auch andere
offizielle Vertreter nicht leicht das
sehen wir in ganz vielen Kontexten auch
bei Fußballspielen das heißt ich finde
man sollte schon noch mal unterscheiden
zwischen was ist hier neu auch was die
Qualität angeht und was sind eigentlich
eher allgemeine grundsätzliche
Problemlagen und ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen seit 20 Jahren gehe ich nicht mehr
raus an Silvester weil es immer schon
also was heißt immer schon ich bin mir
nicht genau sicher ob ich fort also vor
25 Jahren einfach nur risikobereiter war
oder ob es wirklich weniger gefährlich
war aber das ist das ist gefährlich ist
es glaube ich klar und wenn Sie die
Bilder gerade genau gesehen haben da
wurde jedes vorbeifahren der Auto
beschossen das heißt es geht gar nicht
nur gegen die Rettungskräfte oder gegen
die Polizei sondern im Prinzip ist da
jeder ein potentielles eine potenzielles
Ziel so und da wurde ja noch sehr viel
mehr bei diesem Thema unter der Ober ich
zitiere mal Jens Spahn da geht es eher
um umgeregelte Migration um gescheiterte
Integration und fehlenden Respekt vor
dem Start statt um Feuerwerk ja da macht
man sich so einfach
dass das was mit Desintegration zu tun
hat das
keine Frage jemand der sich so benimmt
ist nicht Teil dieser Gesellschaft wie
wir sie gerne ein guter Anfangsverdacht
ja aber ob man dann direkt die gesamte
Migration und Integrationspolitik in
Frage stellt ist dann noch mal eine
andere Frage
und im übrigen
also er bezieht sich ja immer ich habe
das mehrfach gelesen dieses Argument
soll nach dem Motto das geht jetzt
pauschal gegen Migranten nein das finde
ich ja nicht er sagte mit Blick auf
diese Bilder da geht's um gescheiterte
Integration nicht recht
zum Teil wenn man die Statistik sich
anguckt wenn man sieht 145 Festnahmen
und hundert davon sind keine falschen
Staatsbürger zwei Drittel sind Afghanen
und Syrer die dort Randale gemacht haben
in Berlin zum Beispiel
also die Zahl stimmt glaube ich jetzt
nicht so ganz
90 aber
zwei Drittel ja zwei Drittel grob
deswegen so habe ich das gerade
ausgedrückt ja wobei man jetzt ja auch
gesehen hat was genau für Straftaten was
was sind genau grundsätzliche Phänomen
ich habe letzte nachdem wie sehr lange
im Buch von damit Abteil Zermatt gelesen
der einen ein Buch genau zu diesem Thema
jetzt auch wieder veröffentlichen wird
in den nächsten Tagen ein ein ich finde
ziemlich gutes Buch und er sagt da geht
es um eine tiefe Verachtung für den
Staat erster Punkt und zweiter Punkt das
ist die Spitze des Eisberges da brodelt
unter der Oberfläche noch sehr viel mehr
das Gefühl habe ich auch hat er recht
da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher ob man
es so dramatisieren muss was ich hieran
doch relevant finde ist dass es in
bestimmten Stadtteilen passiert und das
sind natürlich Stadtteile die sich nicht
einfach nur durch Migration auszeichnen
sowie Berlin ja auch kein Anteil an
Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund hat
der so viel so weit hoch ähm also über
dem Durchschnitt westdeutscher
Großstädte liegt sondern wir haben hier
mit echt verschärften sozialen
Problemlagen zu tun auch zum Beispiel
mit mit Menschen die geduldet sind mit
neu zugewanderten die es ganz sicher in
bestimmten Quartieren
schwer haben man man muss sich fragen
stellen welche Möglichkeiten Anerkennung
zu bekommen
haben die Menschen da gerade wenn es um
so eine Schaustellung von Männlichkeit
geht das habe ich äh das finde ich ist
auch eine ganz relevante Sache da sieht
man auch wie gutes und schlechtes
zusammenhängt wenn wir uns gerade in
schwierigen Stadtteilen uns anschauen
wie sehr bestimmte junge Männer
zurückfallen dann muss man sich einmal
an muss man einmal feststellen dass sie
bezogen auf Bildung bezogen auf ihre
Perspektive an den Rand gedrängt sind
aber dazu auch noch gerade wenn wir im
migrantischen Milieu schauen junge
Mädchen
relativ erfolgreich sind und nicht nur
dass die erfolgreiche Geschichte nicht
nur dass Sie erfolgreich sind sie
emanzipieren sich darüber hinaus dann
auch brechen alte Rollen musste auf Sie
Sie also ich weiß sie meinen das nicht
so aber ich will noch mal ausdrücklich
sagen weil ich sie ein bisschen kenne
sie wollen jetzt nicht die
Opfergeschichte dieser Typen erzählen
es geht ja gar nicht um Opfer
klingt gerade sowas werden die die Opfer
und die anderen sozusagen nicht wir
wollen verstehen
genau
sagen bevor die die wütende Post gleich
weil ich noch mal sagen will all das was
hier anführen ist sicher richtig aber
doch noch lange keine Begründung für so
etwas das ist keine Rechtfertigung
überhaupt nicht ich sag ja das muss
rechtsstaatlich verfolgt werden
darum geht es ja gar nicht sondern man
muss sich aber trotzdem fragen was sind
die Rahmenbedingungen was sind die
Hintergründe und
da hängt eben Gutes und Schlechtes auch
sehr eng zusammen also
wir haben ja eben wie entspannt zitiert
er hat so nicht pauschal für alle
für diese Gruppe gesagt und für diese
Gruppe hat er recht und wenn er für eine
solche Beschreibung dieses Phänomens aus
der SPD heraus als Nazi beschimpfte
dann trägt diese SPD sind nicht die SPD
war ein Mitglied der SPD aus Bielefeld
dazu bei dass wir dieses Problem nicht
gelöst bekommen wir haben es hier mit
einem veritablen Problem mangelnder
Integration junger Menschen zu tun
überwiegend
Migrationshintergrund und von denen
überwiegend aus der arabischen Welt so
und dieser Staat darf sich dieses
Verhalten nicht bieten lassen aber dann
müssen sie sich sehr schwer wird und ich
widerspreche vor kurzem Ungarn aber an
dieser Stelle tue ich vor kurz weg es
ist kein neues Phänomen die Angriffe auf
Rettungskräfte sehen wir seit Jahren wir
sehen hier eine neue Form der Eskalation
mit diesem Bildern die auch überhaupt
nicht mehr davor zurück schenken das
Verlaufen der Kamera zu tun Feuerlöscher
auf Krankenwagen zu werfen Polizeibeamte
zu attackieren
das sind einfach Dinge die dürfen wir
uns in dieser Gesellschaft nicht bieten
lassen was passiert ja in weil wir jetzt
gerade schon wieder sagen in die
Parteipolitik eintauchen das
interessiert ja in NRW geführten CDU
Innenministerium genauso ich habe ja
nicht gesagt dass das ein Phänomen ist
das auf Berlin beschränkt ist Berlin hat
sonderprobleme zusätzlich aber wir haben
es in Deutschland mit einer zunehmenden
Verrohung zu tun mit einem mangelnden
Respekt und das fängt also weil sie
sozusagen in Deutschland Teilen der
Gesellschaft ja ich habe dieser Tage den
Bericht eines Polizeibeamten gelesen
möglicherweise selbst
Migrationshintergrund gibt ja
unglaublich viele PolizeibeamtInnen
Beamte und so weiter wenn ich dir so
sehe so ja selber Migrationshintergrund
und der beschreibt wie er in einen in
einen Döner Imbiss rein flüchtet was ist
die Gruppe die jetzt pauschal zum Teil
so unter Verdacht steht ist dann der
schützende Hafen der flüchtet der Rhein
ein Polizist dem direkt in die
Schutzweste reingeschossen wird und der
brennt
und dieser Imbissbesitzer sagt wir haben
dann verzweifelt versucht diesen
Polizeibeamten irgendwie zu löschen weil
der brandte tatsächlich lichterloh und
ich habe immer das Gefühl die die Leute
die in den letzten Jahrzehnten auch mit
dieses Land am Laufen gehalten haben die
ärgern sich Rede in diesen Tagen auf
viel nee sprechen teilweise deutlicher
passiert Leben tun ja und ich sag mal
wir tun doch auch vielen Dank also ich
sage das nicht pauschal ich gehöre nicht
zu denen die pauschal sagen diejenigen
die hier als Ausländer leben sind nicht
integriertes Unsinn wir haben hier
Ausländer die sich in diesem Lande
besser verhalten als mancher deutscher
ne aber wir haben ein Problem mit einer
kleinen Gruppe von Ausländern so und
dafür schämen sich manche ihrer
Landsleute die seit Jahrzehnten viele
mehr als manch einer von uns und zwar zu
Recht weil sie einfach sehen dass das
auch ihr Leben diskreditiert so und
deswegen sind wir glaube ich alle
aufgerufen dafür zu sorgen dass dies
hier jetzt sehr schnell beurteilt wird
und zwar nicht ad hoc auf Silvester
bezogen sondern 365 Tage im Jahr muss
die Polizei in diesen Brennpunkten
präsent sein und da muss der die
kleinste Straftat geahndet werden wenn
man diesen Leuten zu viel Spielräume
geben dann drehen die Silvester mit
Alkohol und allem was dazugehört durch
aber Herr März alles was ihr bis jetzt
gesagt haben wunderbar aber wie passt
dazu die vornamenabfrage ich habe die
nicht gemacht aber ich habe sie nicht
gemacht
also ich sag mal ob das jetzt ein
probates Mittel ist herauszufinden wer
da beteiligt war oder nicht ich vertraue
der Statistik die auch von der
Polizeibehörden in Berlin herausgegeben
wird und die ist sehr eindeutig sind
zwei Drittel und ob es jetzt drei
Viertel werden oder nicht ehrlich gesagt
ist mir egal egal
es geht ja nicht um die zwei Drittel
Deutschland geht sondern es geht um die
Frage wie heißen die die eine deutsche
deswegen sage ich ja das jetzt zwei
Drittel sind oder dreiviertel werden ist
doch irrelevant aber das Signal
entscheiden das Signal ist selbst wenn
ihr eingebürgert seid selbst wenn ihr
hier geboren seid am Ende gucken wir uns
noch mal den Vornamen an das Signal ist
das Gegenteil von dem was eine sinnvolle
Zukunft
und das ist ja ein Thema das ist so alt
wie diese ganze Diskussion um die Frage
der doppelten Staatsangehörigkeit geht
und ob diejenigen die mit Doppelpass in
Deutschland leben besser integriert sind
als diejenigen die es nicht tun das
werden wir wieder haben diese Diskussion
um die Frage was geht dabei nicht oder
nicht wissen ob jemand ein Doppelpass
hat das kann natürlich auch jemand sein
der
eingebürgert ist
diese eine Frage ist für mich von
nachgeordneter Bedeutung entscheidend
ist dass wir bei diesen 145 die da
festgenommen worden sind die
Feststellung haben das hundert davon
einen sogenannten Migrationshintergrund
haben und das diese Gruppe die
wesentliche Problemgruppe dieser
Krawalle in Berlin war und was nicht
heißt das ist nicht auch andere gibt und
das ist kein pauschales Urteil über alle
diejenigen die wir in Deutschland leben
haben es hat ja keiner bestritten dass
eben eine Mehrheit Migrationshintergrund
auf jeden Fall hat das kann man schon in
Zahlen ablesen ich möchte noch einen
Satz zu den Zahlen sagen die Berliner
innensenatorin hat die gestern noch mal
präzisiert sie hatte gesagt 145
Straftaten in der Nacht 38 in
Zusammenhang mit Böllern und dann werden
jeweils rund 50 Verfahren geführt
Angriffe Polizei eine Feuerwehr nur um
das einmal einmal so klar zu ziehen bei
den 145 das waren alle Straftaten
genau
ich weiß er sagt das was wir da gerade
sehen ist so habe ich sie verstanden
etwas was schon viel früher in den
Brunnen gefallen ist und Ausdruck einer
zunehmenden sozialen polarisierungsamt
ist glaube ich ausgedrückt was heißt das
jetzt erst einmal klar wir reden es über
die Fakten aber der Eindruck entsteht ja
doch immer auch in der Diskussion das
hat was damit zu tun dass Menschen
arabischen Ursprungs sind oder eine
Migrationsgeschichte haben aber es ist
ja nicht jemand kriminell weil er eine
gewisse Hautfarbe hat eine gewisse
Religion hat sondern das hat das mit dem
Umfeld zu tun indem die Menschen leben
so dass mit Chancen zu tun es hat das
mit Zukunftsperspektiven zu tun wir
sehen nicht nur unter den betroffenen
Gruppen sondern allgemein in vielen
wissenschaftlichen Studien dass das
Vertrauen der Menschen in staatliche
Institutionen massiv abnimmt und nicht
nur in Deutschland das ist kein
deutsches Phänomen das sehen wir überall
im westlichen Ländern da müssen wir uns
Vertrauen in die Justiz nimmt massiv
aber auch in diesem Land wobei kann das
ernsthaft verwundern wenn man hört das
145 Menschen festgenommen werden und 145
am nächsten Tag auf freiem Fuß sind
Frage
ich glaube wir müssen einmal über
Lösungen sprechen natürlich wir haben
jetzt sehr viel über Lösungen der Staat
muss durchgreifen völlig richtig dako
aber ich glaube wenn wir das Problem
lösen wollen müssen wir die Ursachen
sprechen und dann müssen wir uns die
sozialen Ursachen anschauen müssen wir
uns anschauen junge Menschen was haben
wir heute für eine Situation wir haben
knapp zehn Prozent der jungen Menschen
die heute ohne Schulabschluss abgeben
wir hatten Anfang des Jahr oder im
September ungefähr 75.000 junge Menschen
die keinen Ausbildungsplatz hatten wir
sehen dass die die Mietpreise in den
Städten explodieren das
Zukunftsperspektiven für junge Menschen
schlecht sind ich will nicht sagen dass
das eine Rechtfertigung ist es nicht
aber ich glaube wir müssen verstehen
und wir müssen einen Ursachen ansetzen
und die soziale Polarisierung nimmt zu
das ist kein deutsches Unternehmen dass
sie in vielen Ländern schucken sich die
geldwesten Bewegungen in Frankreich an
auch da waren Auslöser die dann wirklich
so auch gewalttätigen Ausscheidung über
eine lange Zeit gekommen ist also wir
müssen die die Ursachen adressieren und
da machen wir es uns zu leicht wenn wir
sagen der der Staat muss mit aller Härte
durchgreifen das muss er aber viel
klüger ist Prävention und Prävention
heißt man muss die Ursachen adressieren
und die hat nun mal sehr stark auch was
mit Zukunftschancen zu tun die Frage
dass viele junge Menschen einfach das
Gefühl haben ist kümmert sich niemand um
mich ich habe keine Zukunftsperspektive
und das ist einer der Kernprobleme die
wir interessieren müssen
woher kommt dieses Gefühl mich kümmert
sich keiner als zeigen übrigens auch
Umfragen dass die Leute zunehmend das
Gefühl haben ich meine in einem Land wie
diesen bei dem man häufig das Gefühl hat
es wird sich eigentlich um fast alles
gekümmert
und fehlende Perspektive tut mir leid
bei dem Land wie Deutschland fehlt mir
auch jedes Verständnis wenn jemand hier
etwas vom Leben möchte da kann das hier
haben wenn sich jemand hier anstrengend
nach wie vor ich weiß dass die soziale
Durchlässigkeit möglicherweise gelitten
hat in den letzten Jahren aber trotzdem
wenn sie sind doch das beste Beispiel
dafür wenn sich jemand anstrengen in
diesem Land dann kann er was werden aus
eigener Kraft woher dann diese
Verachtung für diesen Staat also wie
gesagt ich weiß nicht von der Gruppe
über die wir jetzt heute Abend hier
reden ja also es ist es gibt eine Gruppe
und das
Überschneidung zu diesem Krawallen geben
die von der öffentlichen Ordnung von
öffentlichen Sicherheit und Ordnung
nicht viel halten weil sie auch wenig
profitieren selber wenig sich sich in
der Gesellschaft mit wiederfinden und
dementsprechend dann unter Umständen
Freude daran entwickeln Widerstand zu
leisten und auch Attacken gegen diese
soziale in Ordnung zu zu schaffen aber
wenn man wenn man das muss man
unterscheiden es gibt eine Gruppe die
ist wirklich und und das ist ganz sicher
in so sehr gregierten Stadtteilen eben
konzentriert die haben ganz verstärkt
von mit Perspektivlosigkeit zu tun und
dann hatten sie dann sehen wir bei
jungen Menschen das allgemeine Phänomen
das und das ist die Masse das ist
individuell alles voller Chancen in
Deutschland ist und wir aber
gesamtgesellschaftlich irgendwie
Klima Krisen die Weltordnung und so
weiter dass sie junge Menschen in im
Kontext globaler Krisen aufwachsen na
Zukunftslosigkeit und wenn Zukunft wenn
über Zukunft gesprochen wird dann sind
das Horrorvision und gleichzeitig aber
und das ist sozusagen der die der
Spannungsfeld haben die meisten jungen
Menschen ideale Situation gerade weil
der demografische Wandel jetzt
stattfindet können die sich im Prinzip
die Jobs aussuchen und das heißt für die
eher privilegierten die sozusagen eine
individuell gute Zukunftsperspektive
haben gibt es das Spannungsfeld und
gleichzeitig haben wir eine doch
nennenswerte Zahl auch wenn es eine
relativ kleine Gruppe ist die
tatsächlich von
ihrer Qualifikation von
ihren Zukunftschancen sehr eingeschränkt
sind und das ist glaube ich eher dass
Phänomen ist das ein gewisser Weise auch
ein ein Moment der eine echte Chance
bietet weil wir es ist mein Eindruck
endlich mal offen und klar und deutlich
über etwas reden was sonst immer nur
vernuschelt wird ganz bestimmt denn das
ist ein Problem das ist ja gewachsen das
sind verfestigte Strukturen verfestigte
Perspektivlosigkeit das ist weder
in letztes Jahr passiert ist es
entstanden noch in den letzten zwei drei
Jahren sondern es hatten eine sehr lange
Geschichte eine Geschichte im übrigen
die auch damit zu tun hat
[Musik]
Duldung die Art und Weise wie überhaupt
unsere Zielperspektive was
Integrationspolitik angeht deswegen bin
ich immer so ein bisschen vorsichtig
wenn die Integrationspolitik
angesprochen wird
was ist eigentlich das Ziel der
Integrationspolitik wir haben viel zu
viele Duldungen kettendungen
wir haben im Prinzip erkennt man keine
Strategie es gibt nicht eine
Integrationspolitik sondern es gibt ein
Flickenteppich und der Flickenteppich
ist in bestimmten Kontext gerade in
solchen offenbar nicht sonderlich
produktiv